bonjour c'est cyprien et aujourd'hui je
vais faire une vidéo sur la sncf sans
évoquer le retard des trains c'est une
première on n'a jamais vu ça en france
je prends assez souvent le train j'ai
moins de 25 ans j'ai donc une carte
12-25 appelée aussi la carte que tu
oublies tout le temps ça fait des années
que je l' ai je la change tous les ans
et je l'oubli à chaque fois pas qu'une
seule fois gelé sur moi alors j'ai
trouvé une solution
merci votre carte de réduction s'il vous
plaît c'est vrai je me la suis greffé
sur le corps voilà comme ça je peux plus
oublié
j'ai fait pareil avec ma carte navigo
mais avant de monter dans le corps il
faut composté son billet un c'est
obligatoire c'est vite fait de compost
un billet safran quoi 35 minutes
d'ailleurs la machine te demande tout le
temps de retourner ton billet ça me
change absolument rien et quand enfin
j'ai réussi à composter son billet c'est
là que je remarque qu'il était prêt
composter je suis un boulet alors il ya
plein de choses que je n'aime pas dans
la sncf à la machine à composter les
wagons bas à vous aurez votre sandwich
est périmé c'est pas la date de
péremption c'est le prix je vous le rend
en fait j'ai perdu ma carte bleue mais
c'est pas pour autant que je vais mettre
à frauder un an je paye tous mes billets
tout ça parce que la fraude c'est pas
fait pour moi bonjour est ce que je fais
un peu tous ces mois refermez mora je ne
mérite pas de vivre me récupérer mon sac
à côté de vous s'il vous plaît il ya un
autre truc qui me fait extrêmement
flipper dans les trains je ne dors
jamais dans un train voilà j'avais je
peux être l'homme le plus fatigué du
monde
non je ne dors pas pour une raison
extrêmement simple garde de bamako deux
minutes d'arrêt je répète gare de bamako
deux minutes d'arrêt et le plus grand
mystère de la sncf pour moi c'est quand
le train est arrêté sur la voie et qu'on
entend ça
le train est actuellement arrêté sur la
voie pour votre sécurité
veuillez ne pas tenter d'ouvrir les
portes cette année ça veut dire qu'on
peut ouvrir les portes c'est ça quand
j'entends ça moi j'ai envie d'essayer
on s'est complètement con comme message
je suis sûr qu'il ya des gens qui
meurent tous les jours à cause de ça bah
oui j'étais sûr
si vous avez quelque chose contre la
sncf si la sncf a quelque chose contre
vous partager ma vidéo sur facebook et
rejoignez la page aussi on s'amuse comme
des fous
barbecue tous les midis ça et toutes mes
autres vidéos sont sur cyprien point fr
je sais pas pourquoi je suis chaude et
puis finalement il me casse les couilles
est toujours en retard
[Musique]